SUBJECT 1: At first,
when we were kids,
we've always wanted to help
other people in our own way
and to do something
that is rewarding.
SUBJECT 2: It was sort of
a simple decision for us.
We just know that we're
passionate in what we do.
And what we're good at is
being compassionate to others.
SUBJECT 1: I think the biggest
challenge of being twins
is assuming that
we're always the same.
But actually, that's not
really the case 100%.
SUBJECT 2: As we grew
up, we found our way.
And we found what
our differences are.
And people usually
also pick up on that.
SUBJECT 1: Now that we're
graduating from our doctorate
degree, we hope to be able to
work as nurse practitioners.
SUBJECT 2: And
whatever challenge
that comes in your
way, you will always
have the say in how
you end your day
and give back to people
that also supported you.